>>Reto Meier: Good morning, everyone.
Thanks for coming along today and squeezing
in. It's a big crowd in here today. So thanks
for your patience as well. I know we are starting
a bit late but the keynote went over a little.
It was hopefully interesting and exciting
for you all.
My name is Reto Meier. I am a developer advocate
for Android at Google and today I am going
to talk to you about how to get started developing
for Android.
Before I do get started, I want to point your
attention to this bit.ly link. We are going
to be doing live waves for each of the sessions
at Google I/O this year. So if you want to
become a part of that, have some conversations
with people at the session or reading your
notes from afar, follow this link to ioandroid1
bit.ly link. If you want to tweet about it,
the tweet tag for this session is Android1
as well.
One of the things I like to ask whenever I
do these sessions is how many people in the
room have Android phones?
Wow! That's phenomenal!
How many have the coolest new phones like
a Droid or a Nexus One or something like that?
That's incredible.
In fairness, how many of you had these phones
before we sent them to you for coming along?
That's pretty respectable, I have to say.
I am impressed. That's great. It's even better
to see you guys here with the phone, trying
to be involved in how to create apps for it.
What is Android? Android is an open source,
open platform for mobile development.
You know what? I feel like I have given this
slide before, and if I have a look in the
audience I feel like I have probably given
this slide to a few of you beforehand.
Is there anyone here who doesn't know a little
bit about Android, at least?
Let's ask it a little differently. How many
of you have downloaded the SDK and maybe installed
Eclipse and the plug-in?
Wow!
And how many of you have done your first apps,
something a little more than Hello World.
So that's most of you.
So we can probably skip this really basic
stuff. We had a boot camp yesterday. All of
this information is online at developer.android.com.
So if you really do want to understand the
absolute fundamentals, check this out. It's
got everything you need. It will tell you
all about the APIs that are included, give
you tutorials, sample apps, those sorts of
things.
What we're going to do today I think is something
a little bit different. In the past, it's
been all about, as a developer advocate, telling
people about Android, getting them excited.
I think judging by the number of people with
Android phones and who have already gotten
started, we are a little beyond that.
Now it's about quality, building better applications.
So instead today I am going to present to
you some best practices for beginners on Android
to help make sure that you guys, when you
get started are creating great apps, not just
any app.
So as a developer, you have a choice. You
can be a good developer, or you can be a lazy
developer.
And like any choice, that choice has consequences.
As a developer, you are absolutely at the
mercy of your users. If you create a bad user
experience, they are going to uninstall your
app, they are going to give you one star,
they are going to write a snarky comment,
and before you know it your app is going to
disappear. It's going to drop down the list
of top apps.
When people do find it through a search, it
will have one star. They won't bother with
it. If they do, they have a bad experience,
they do the same thing. Before you know it,
your app is gone.
On the other hand, if you are a good developer,
if you use some of these best practices, then
you are going to create an app people love,
they are going to use it, keep using it, give
it higher rankings, positive comments. It's
going to show up on the top lists. It's going
to be the app with four and a half stars when
they do a search. People are going to talk
about it, people are going to use it, it's
got a potential for being featured. This is
what you want.
So on the assumption what you guys want do
is become good developers, what I want to
talk to you today is I want to give you five
examples of things you should not do, five
examples of things that you should do, and
then in the last ten or 15 minutes I want
to give you a couple of practical examples
of areas within Android development where
a few simple best practices can really improve
the quality of your applications, make them
more useful and more performant within the
system.
So we are going to start off with the five
deadly since of Android development.
First one is sloth. It is key that your applications
are fast and responsive at all times.
The two golden rules for creating performant
applications within Android are to not do
any work that you don't need to do and not
to allocate any memory if you can possibly
avoid it.
Now, the Android developer Web site, developer@android.com
has a whole list of performace pointers, some
of which are summarized here. I am not going
to go through each of these in detail. It's
on the Web site. You can do that there. But
what you will find that all of these have
in common is they in some way or another refer
back to the previous two golden rules. They
don't do any work if they don't have to do
it, and they avoid allocating memory, such
as creating objects, if they can.
The reason why this is so important is because
small changes in efficiency within your application
in such a resource constrained environment
as mobile phones can have a significant impact
on the performance of your applications.
So even things which you probably would never
have considered, and many of these certainly,
from a desktop developing background that
I am from, I wouldn't have given a second
thought to because they seem like such minor
improvements in terms of efficiency, in a
resource constrained environment this can
have a significant impact and is something
you really do need to pay attention to.
Just as important as performance, if not more
so, is responsiveness.
So mobile users, they do not have any patience.
You are all mobile users and you know what
it's like. Your mobile phone is something
you are using on the go. It's not something
you are sitting down comfortably in front
of a workstation where you are waiting for
something to load. Basically everything has
to happen immediately.
And the same is true for your applications.
So you have to make sure users have the instant
gratification. What that means is you don't
want to have modal loading dialogues where
people are seeing a spinning beach ball or
hourglass or anything along those lines. They
need to be able to interact with your application
instantly.
So if you are creating something like a news
app, for example, rather than having a loading
dialogue which comes up and prevents the user
from doing anything, what you want to do is
allow them to continue to interact while updating
them on progress and then showing them whatever
information you can as quickly as you can.
So that means downloading the news headlines
and filling them in as you decode them from
the input stream.
Going back afterwards and adding the images
as they get downloaded, so rather than waiting
until everything is finished and ready to
go, you are gradually increasing the amount
of information available.
And you can extend this to things such as
prefetching. So again if it's a news app,
something like that, you fill in the information
for the first screen, and then while they
are reading that or while the user is doing
anything else, you are prefetching the dialer
for each of the sections they may navigate
to. And the intent here is as soon as the
user is using the application, they are not
having to wait any longer for things. It's
available as soon as it possibly can be. And
this is particularly important for something
like a mobile phone where your data bandwidth
is going to be limited. It's going to take
some time for a lot of these things to load.
So you need to do everything you can to remove
that lagginess.
How many have you have seen one of these?
Yeah, come on, I think a few more than that.
If your user sees one of these, you have already
failed. It's absolutely the worst thing you
can possibly have your user see.
The documentation will rightly tell you that
you will see one of those "application not
responding" dialogues if the user tries to
perform an action on your phone and the device
isn't responsive within five seconds. So you
have five seconds to respond before you get
the ANR of death. That's absolutely true.
It's also a little bit misleading. In reality
you have between one and 200 milliseconds
before your users are going to start thinking
your application is laggy.
So it's important that you move anything which
can in any way take longer than just a fraction
of the second and interrupt the UI flow that
you move it into a background thread. There's
a number of ways you can do that. The most
simple and straightforward is to use Java
threading to move all those time-consuming
operations into a thread. Of course that brings
with it a whole a lot of issues such as synchronizing
to the UI thread so you can update progress
and change the UI depending on the progress
of your background activity.
So what we have created in Android is a class
called async task. And what this does is it
wraps up that model for you. So rather than
having to do all of the thread handling yourself
in the UI synchronization, you can implement
this class and have it do it for you.
So it's a generic class so all of the parameters
here can be defined to whichever types that
you want to use.
In this example, I have kept it simple and
left it as void.
So as you can see, the "do in background"
event handler is where you actually do this
time-consuming operation. While that's happening
you can regularly publish progress. So if
you are downloading multiple pictures and
you want to update the UI with each picture
as it comes through or simply update a progress
dialogue as you are performing this action,
you can call publish progress, optionally
passing the parameter, and that's going fire
this on-progress update handler, receiving
that parameter if you pass one through. And
this is already synchronized to the UI thread.
So you can update your UI, you can trigger
a notification, call up a toast, anything
like that and you don't have to do the thread
synchronization work.
Similarly, once you have completed your background
processing task you can optionally return
a value, that's going to get passed on to
on post execute. And this is synchronized
to the UI thread. You can modify the UI with
the data you have been progressing, notify
your users it's complete, anything like that,
and the synchronization is already done for
you.
The next sin is that of gluttony. The only
thing worse than having an app that is slow
and unresponsive is an app which makes the
system slow and unresponsive and drains all
of your battery as well just for good measure.
The key is to always use your system resources
responsibly.
So to avoid being a bad citizen, what you
want to do is make sure you are being very
respectful of power. Don't use power unless
you absolutely have to. Don't do updates more
often than you need to, either. And that can
be updates from location listeners, from accelerometers,
widget updates, anything that's going to cause
the phone to wake up or to listen to a sensor
or do any kind of action. You want to do this
as infrequently as possible. Obviously there's
tradeoffs there against usability, but it's
still important to find out what's the minimum
amount we can do that's still going to make
it a useful, usable application.
Things you should do. Find ways to share data.
Processing data, pulling it down through the
network, all of these things are going to
consume resources. Battery, Internet bandwidth.
If you can find ways that your application
can share that data between other applications,
whether it's yourselves or third parties,
or if you can leverage data from another application
or from something Natively, this is an opportunity
to reduce that resource use.
Similarly, wherever possible you should be
event driven. So there are some circumstances
where you will need to do polling. That's
the way it is at the moment certainly. But
wherever possible you should be listening
for system events or for broadcast intents
from your application or others. We will talk
a little bit more about how you go about doing
that later in this session.
Possibly one of the most important things
is to let the system manage resources. So
a lot of the Android framework team, their
whole goal is to find ways of being able to
make the framework manage these resources.
So it's important to try and find ways that
you can work with the system to take advantage
of those optimizations. And importantly, not
try and fight against what the system is doing.
How many of you are familiar with the wake
lock?
All right. I may very well regret showing
you this but this is a wake lock. What it
is, it's a way to force the device to stay
on, so you can keep just the CPU running or
you can keep the screen on as well. And that's,
in fact, what this particular example shows.
We're using the power manager to create a
new wake lock, which is going to keep the
screen on, though optionally dimmed. And then
what we're doing is calling acquire, and at
that point the screen and the CPU is going
to be kept on until this wake lock is released.
So in this example we have specified a ten
second timeout. So no matter what happens,
it's going to be released after ten seconds
unless we release it first by calling release.
Wake locks are really cool, they are really
useful, and very important. Particularly,
you've got things happening in the background,
if you have got things happening in a regular
basis or responding to system events which
may occur while your device is on standby,
you need to use wake locks to make sure it
doesn't turn off while you're in the middle
of completing a task.
The thing is this. They are very powerful,
but it also requires a lot of responsibility
on your behalf.
So if you are using wake locks, you need to
make sure that you really need to use one.
It's tempting to just use it wherever you
can. Oh, this is something that should be
completed. Unless it needs to be completed
within a certain period of time, don't use
a wake lock.
If you do need to use one, use the minimum
level of wake lock possible, and use it for
the shortest amount of time that you possibly
can.
So that's the -- in the example that we gave
that you just saw previously, we had a ten-second
timeout to make sure that no matter what happens,
it will be ended in that time frame.
So this is an important thing to do to make
sure you are not holding wake locks and draining
the battery unnecessarily.
One of the others things I want to point out
is that in most cases, you shouldn't actually
need to keep the screen on. Certainly the
CPU, but the screen you shouldn't have to.
Now, if you are creating an application which
does need the screen to be on, a video player
or something like that where the user isn't
interacting but you want the screen on, there
is an alternative, and that's to let the window
manager handle it for you.
So rather than using a wake lock to keep your
screen on, what you can do is get a handle
of the window and pass this "keep screen on"
flag to it, and that will let the window manager
handle the wake lock for you. That way you
don't have to worry about finding out all
the different ways your activity can be hidden,
when it should or shouldn't be keeping a screen
on, and managing these wake locks. You are
essentially letting the run time do that four.
It's a much safer, much more secure way of
doing things.
Please don't be the developer which makes
the user pull the battery. Don't be hostile.
Don't fight your users. You are there to create
an experience which is good for them, and
they should be one of the -- they should always
be your top priority.
You absolutely live and die by your user's
experience. So you absolutely need to make
it a good one. And you need to respect those
user expectations for the way your application
behaves.
When I asked my team for some best practices
around Android development, what sort of things
should I share with you guys, this is one
of the quotes that I got back. Doing what
the user expects with respect to navigation
flow is absurdly important for overall user
satisfaction. I really like this because it
summed up a few thoughts I had and which were
particularly important to me when explaining
to people how they should be creating the
user experiences.
Users have been using their phones for a lot
longer than they have been using your apps.
And they have been using other apps that are
on the phone longer than using yours as well
so they have expectations for the way applications
behave. Interfering with those expectations
just makes it harder for them to use your
app.
So while you do need to make sure it's always
easy and intuitive to learn and use your application,
you also need to think about it in the greater
context of an Android device. One of the particular
ones I want to call out to you today is the
back button. The back button on Android is
a little bit unique. It's not something you
see in a lot of other mobile platforms but
it's also integral to the way people use their
phones. The key to the back button is in the
name. It means back. It's going back to something
you have already seen. You should never be
seeing a new screen when you hit back. It
works the same way, or at least it should
work the same way as the back button on your
browser. Every time you hit back on your browser
you are going to a previous Web page or Web
site that you have already been to. You are
not navigating to the home page of a new site.
So if you navigate from one site to another
and then within pages, hitting back will always
take you back through these other places,
and that's exactly the way it should act within
your application. It's not an up button. It's
a back button.
So of course respecting the user expectations
in terms of navigation is definitely one important
part, but it's not the only expectation that
you need to respect.
Phones are really extremely personal devices.
They are something which people use their
phones in ways which are unique to them and
they will have work flows built around those
expectations. So again, it's important you
not interfere with the way they expect to
be able Tuesday their phones.
So what does that mean? It means there's a
whole bunch of things, again, which are around
Android. And because it's so open, you can
pretty much take control of the user experience
in any way you want to. And one of the ways
in which people do that is by hiding the status
bar.
The thing about that is that it's great, you
get an extra 20 or so pixels at the top of
your display, and if you are creating a game,
this is an absolutely legitimate thing to
do. You want to complete a fully immersive
full-screen experience, and users have an
expectation that that's the way it's going
to work. But I have seen apps do this just
because they would like to have a bit of extra
space. What they may not appreciate is by
doing something like that, the user loses
then their status bar, which means they don't
get the clock, they don't get notifications,
they don't get a variety of things which they
are expecting to be there. It makes it harder
for them to understand your app and to use
it. They are much more likely to try to find
someone else who has done the same sort of
thing as you but are letting them use their
phone in way they are familiar with.
So it's really important that you not hijack
the way in which people use it, so they can
continue to use their phone in ways they have
personalized for themselves while also making
use of your application.
So far the previous three points have all
been sort of implicit expectations or contracts
with the user. It's the expectation that your
app will work well within the context of Android.
This fourth point is much more explicit. It's
the idea of obeying what users have explicitly
told that you they want your application to
do.
This is particularly important around things
like location privacy and anything which has
a cost implication.
Particularly for something like location privacy,
that can even have legal implications in some
countries where if you don't give the users
the option to opt out, then you can run into
real problems.
So one of the system settings that you can
do on your Android phones is to turn off background
data transfer. So I don't know how many of
you knew that. What I am curious to know is
how many of you do know that that's something
which each application has to respect individually?
All right. So this is how do you that. This
is how you find out whether or not a user
has enabled background data transfer.
Using the connectivity manager, it's a simple
call to get background data setting.
There's also an intent that gets fired if
the user changes this. So what that means
is if this is turned off, then your application
is not allowed to transfer data in the background.
Now, it still can. It's up to you to turn
it off. But it's something the user isn't
expecting, so if it is transferring data in
the background and the user is getting hit
for a thousand dollar roaming phone bill,
it's you they are going to be angry at. So
it's really important that you respect that.
The next sin is that of arrogance. Don't fight
the system. It will most likely win.
What do I mean by don't fight the system?
It's doing things like not using unsupported
-- or I should say, undocument APIs. And
it's important, I will say it twice. The reason
for this is pretty straightforward. It's for
your own good. It's not for any other reason
than the fact if they are not documented,
the reason for that more often than not is
because we think it's going to change.
So we can use these undocumented APIs. It's
all open source. You can see everything that's
there, there is nothing to prevent you, but
then when the next release of Android comes
out, your app is going to break. And you are
going to have to spend a lot of time trying
to figure out how to then make it work with
this new version possibly even before you
have that update on your phone or even the
SDK to do anything about it.
So it's really important that you think long
and hard before you use anything that's not
officially supported.
Just as important, and this kind of goes back
to the topics we were just talking about previously,
and that's make sure that your application
is consistent with the system. Don't try and
fight against the way that the system normally
works, because that's going to be in line
with the user expectations. It's going to
make it easier for the system to optimize
resources.
So try to find ways to work with the system
rather than try to find ways to work against
it.
Related to that is respecting the application
life cycle model. So you have all got the
SDK, you have all gotten started which means
hopefully you are aware of the application
life cycle within Android.
So what that means is that there's a bunch
of ways that your application can be switched
out; in fact, can be terminated by the run
time to reclaim resources for other running
activities.
So it's really important that you use things
like on pours, on stop, on start, on restart
to make sure that that transition is invisible
to your users.
As far as they are concerned, your application
should always just be sitting there a moment
away from being the active foreground activity.
So you should be saving state, saving data,
caching things so they are not having to restart
the app each time they switch to it. They
are simply switching a back.
So the final five, the final sin I want to
cover is that of discrimination. Design for
everyone.
One of the big strengths of Android is there
are a huge number of handsets. If you have
been out the front here you will be able to
see this massive bookcase of Android phones.
And there's a few dozen there at least. And
it's all different screen sizes, hardware
types, supported things.
And many of them are running different platforms.
So this is the latest breakdown of the different
platforms that are available.
So you can see right away that if you are
targeting a single platform, you are already
cutting out two-thirds of your users.
If you are targeting a single device, then
that's going to be even more extreme. So you
need to find ways to include everyone.
At the same time, if you design for the lowest
denominator, you are going to be restricting
two-thirds of your users from having some
of these advanced features.
So there are ways you can support everyone
can while symptom including the advanced API
features for the people who have those platforms
running on their phone.
The key to that is to not make any assumptions.
It's to design for multiple displays. It's
to design expecting internationalization right
from the beginning. It's all about externalizing
everything you can so you can support as many
different locations, languages, and features
as possible.
So how do you go about doing that?
The key is externalization. There's a resources
framework within Android that's very powerful
which lets you externalize pretty much anything.
So you should never have a hard coded anything
in your code.
If it's a string value, a dimension value,
anything like that, colors, they should all
be externalized into the resources hierarchy
so that you can have different variations
for different locations, different hardware.
And so you can create an optimized experience
for everyone who is using your application.
Even within resources, if you are creating
an array of strings, each of the values within
that array resource should be a link to another
resource, the string resources.
So the way that actually looks is like this.
So within your project folder you have a resources
subdirectory or RES subdirectory which contains
the resources. And as you can see on the right-hand
side here we have done that for string values.
So we have different values localized for
a number of different languages.
On the left-hand side we have done something
similar for assets. So you have got three
different icons for the different resolution
categories supported, and optimized layouts
for each of the screen sizes as well.
Now, run time, Android is going to go through,
look at the device that it's running on, and
pick the right values from all of these things.
And so you as the developer don't have to
do anything other than have these externalized
resources, and you are going to get the best
possible result that any variation of the
hardware that your application is running
on.
I could go on about this for the rest of my
hour. I won't because Justin is going to do
that this afternoon. So if you are interested
in exactly how you can do these things, things
like using reflection, things like using these
resources hierarchy to be able to create this
optimized experience for as many users as
possible, I strongly urge you to check that
out this afternoon.
So that neatly covers everything that you
need to avoid.
So I want to lift the mood a little and cover
a few things that you really should be looking
at doing.
So it's the five glorious virtues of Android
development.
The first one is that of beauty.
How many people in the room are designers?
We've got a couple.
Nice.
Thanks for coming.
How many of you guys who aren't designers
still create the assets and do the work flows
and the user experience and the layouts and
everything for your applications?
Yeah.
That's actually fewer than I thought.
I think some of you are a little shy.
But even still, if you are serious about this,
if you really want to create an application
that's great rather than just good, you need
to be serious about the way your application
looks.
You need to be looking to hire one of the
first lot of guys which put their hand up.
So, hopefully, you'll be popular later in
the day.
Beauty is important.
If you are designing and implementing the
designs which people do for you, there is
a session again today at 4:15, after Justin's,
on Android UI design patterns.
So that's going to talk a little bit about
the sorts of work flows and user experiences
that are standard within Android and how you
can go about implementing those in an efficient
way.
So if you're involved in the UI design implementation
of your applications, and I think it is fair
to say that most of you will be, then this
is definitely a session you will want to check
out.
Rather than going into too much detail, given
that there is this session later in the day,
I want to go over a few specific points while
I have your attention.
The first one is to create assets for large
devices.
So so far, the trend has been increasing resolution,
increasing sizes.
And there's no reason to believe that that's
going to go anywhere other than continue to
move in that direction.
So what you need to do is make sure that you
create those assets as big as possible.
So that means scalable vector art or large
raster images which can then be scaled down
and optimized for the lower resolutions.
The key thing, really, is being resolution-independent
entirely.
It's -- we're no longer in this place where
you can assume that mobile phone screen sizes
are going to be a particular size or a particular
resolution.
There's also a whole collection of different
screen sizes and slight variations in resolution.
Your best bet is to be independent of that
wherever you can be.
So use device-independent pixels, use relative
layouts, all of these things, which we have
had to be doing in Web and desktop development
for a long time.
It's the same situation for mobiles.
You can't make assumptions about the screen
that your apps will be running on.
Two things which I do want to point out, because
you guys are new to Android, these two tools
layout opt and hierarchy view.
These are within the SDK tools folder of the
SDK download.
They will help you to analyze and then optimize
your layouts.
Once you've worked out what it is you want
to display, this will help to make sure that
you implement that in a way that's efficient
and performant.
So definitely check those out.
So for the next few virtues, what I want to
do is, rather than just talking about it,
I want to show you a couple of examples of
applications which make use of some of these
virtues.
So the first example I want to give is that
of generosity.
It's the idea of sharing and consuming functionality
within your own application so you can bring
multiple applications together and the example
is Where and Open Table.
Where is an application which lets you find
things, like restaurants.
Open Table is an application which lets you
book tables at restaurants.
So it should be fairly simple to see how these
two things should be able to work together.
And that's what I want to demonstrate now.
Brilliant.
Okay.
So if I open up Where, look for places, restaurants,
American, in the local area.
Excellent.
We'll have a look at Sauce here.
Four and a half stars.
That looks quality.
So, you know, as you'd expect from any of
these sorts of sites, it's got a picture,
it's got ratings, phone number, which we can
use to dial the restaurant and make a booking.
And down at the bottom here, we have a "reserve
now" button.
If I press that, it opens Open Table, which
then has a look at the restaurant which we've
typed in, which is Sauce.
Lets us find a table.
Gives us the options for what times are available.
We can click that and then make that booking.
I won't make the booking, because there's
an after party at Google I/O tonight.
So I'm going to go to that instead.
Just to show these are two separate applications,
we can open Open Table separately from that
icon there.
So I think that's really cool.
I think that's something which a lot of applications
can make use of.
So the question is, how do they go about doing
something like that?
And it's through using intents, and intents
are one of the most fundamental things about
Android and the power of it and the way things
actually work, the way you glue together different
activities in different -- either within your
own application or between multiple applications.
So using intents, you can share this functionality
and leverage functionality from other people
the way Where and Open Table have done so
today.
So rather than just talk about it, I'm going
to show exactly how they go about doing that.
The way you do it is, you create a new intent.
An intent consists of an action you want to
perform and some data that you want to perform
that action on.
Within your own application, you may choose
to start an activity by creating an intent
that specifies the context and a particular
activity class that you want to load.
That's what I call like an explicit intent.
You're saying open this activity.
I know which one it is.
What this demonstrates is a way to create
an implicit intent.
You're saying, I don't know which application
can do this, but I want someone to be able
to fulfill this booking action against this
hotel.
I'm just going to start an activity in the
hope that someone is able to do that.
There are ways to peek to make sure that an
activity does exist, to point people to the
market if there's a particular application
that you would like to suggest to them to
use to fulfill it.
On the other side, if you had this application
which can fulfill this request, the way that
you announce that to the system is to add
an intent filter to your activity node in
the manifest.
And here what you're saying is, I'm capable
of performing this booking action on this
hotel name data.
And so you can see when the -- when the previous
application calls this intent, intent resolution
is going to go through, find this filter,
and it's going to cause this activity to start.
Within the activity, you can then call get
intent to find the intent that was used to
start this activity.
So it's going to be this booking intent which
we had in the previous slides, call get action
and get data to get the action and data to
confirm that it's the action that you want
to perform.
Pull out the data, in this case, it will be
the hotel name, and then you can use this
to populate your form.
In the case of Open Table, that's obviously
a -- you know, the restaurant name and the
ability to make those bookings.
It can be something similar or different for
hotels or for any other action that you can
think of in any other kind of data.
Update the UI, allow the user to complete
the action, and then when they hit "okay"
or "cancel" you can set a result.
In this case, we've said okay.
The null parameter there is actually an intent.
So you can, for example, using the full intent
data, add extras to this calling intent which
has, say, an affiliate code.
Then you can return an intent which has something,
for example, a booking reference number.
So you can pass this data backwards and forwards
beyond just starting a new activity and including
it within your work flow, you can actually
have data passing between these applications
anonymously.
And this is really -- this is really powerful.
And to me, this is something that I hope you
that guys, as -- as beginners to Android,
really have a think about.
If you're creating an app, if you have some
functionality, how can other people use it?
How can I expose parts of my work flow to
give another way in for users to be able to
get access to that, even if they're not launching
my app from the start menu or from the launcher
or from the home screen.
And at the same time, if you've got an application,
how can I leverage what other people have
done?
How can I use that within my own application
to provide users with more functionality?
So it's -- I think it's really exciting.
I hope it's something that you guys take away
and have a real think about.
The next virtue is that of ubiquity.
And for this, I'm going to use one of my own
-- one of my own applications, just to demonstrate
the sorts of things that you can do to make
your app more than just an icon on the launcher.
So, again, you can see the application shortcut.
It's an earthquake.
What it does is pulls the U.S. geological
society's earthquake RSS feed and gives you
a list of all of the most recent earthquakes
and what the magnitude was.
But the reason I want to show it to you today
is just to show the different ways in which
you can have your application be used by the
user or visible to the user.
So the first things you'll notice here is,
obviously, we've got two different home screen
widgets.
We've also got live folders.
So this "all quakes" small icon on the top
right, if we click that, it's using a content
provider to give us a list of all of the last
earthquakes which the application has found.
So, again, users can have that on their home
screen.
We've also got a shortcut here.
And if we have a look at the status bar, we've
also got notification.
So at the moment, I have it sent to poll regularly.
Whenever a new earthquake is detected, it's
going to fire a notification, the same way
as you would get for e-mail, which, as you
can see, shows the last location time and
magnitude.
So -- I mean, these are all fairly straightforward
things.
And they're really easy to do.
What it does is makes your application more
noticeable, it provides more access points
for users to get to your application functionality.
So by doing things like creating widgets,
populating your search results from your own
application into the quick search box, using
live folders, live wallpapers, notifications,
all of these things, it provides you a way
to really expand the engagement of your application.
And what we have found is, the more engaged
people are, the more different ways they find
to interact with your application, the stickier
it becomes, the less likely they are to want
to install it, the more likely they are to
find more ways and more opportunities to use
that application.
So the -- excuse me.
The next virtue I want to cover is that of
utility.
So you can create and launch almost any application
that you want to in the Android Market.
It doesn't necessarily mean that you should.
There are 30,000, or over 30,000 apps in the
market already.
Which means if you create something, you need
to find a way to stand out.
That means being useful or being interesting.
Ideally, it's being both.
So one of the -- one of the applications that
I want to demonstrate for this purpose is
actually -- it's not particularly exciting,
though, you know, your mileage may vary, I
suppose.
What it does, it's an app called from (inaudible)
which is an online grocery store in the U.K.
And I use this to do my shopping so I can
do it from my home.
What it does, it's fairly straightforward,
it lets you shop.
And the key to it is that it's a particularly
useful app.
That's something I need to do, something that
I don't particularly enjoy doing.
And this app tries to make it as simple for
me as possible.
One of the features it does is it does all
of this offline.
So the first thing it does is downloads the
entire catalogue, which it keeps synched,
and you can, in fact, see the catalogue sync
starting in the background, which will let
me browse and do my shopping while I'm on
the underground, which on the U.K. doesn't
have any Wi-Fi or 3G access.
So I can still do the shopping while I don't
have any Internet connectivity, which is helpful
for me.
They've also made use of a couple of really
nice features within Android to make this
even more useful.
The first is voice search.
So if I hit the microphone icon, bananas.
Oops.
Come on, Internet.
You can see that it will search through its
database, and with any luck,
it will display loading.
No, it will show you some bananas, which is
helpful.
So this is a great way that I can do my grocery
shopping while reading through recipes or
wandering through my kitchen and I can just
hit this button and call out the things that
I want to shop and add them to my basket,
which I think is really neat.
The final thing I want to demonstrate is bar
code scanning.
Again, they're using this idea of being able
to integrate other applications so that, again,
I can just hit -- sorry.
So it's a box of tomato puree.
So, again, I can hit the bar code button.
What that's going to do is open up the bar
code scanner, which you can see.
Which is a third-party application, bar code
scanner, which, hopefully, some of you guys
have installed for today to do the scavenger
hunt.
That finds it for me.
Again, these things, they're not -- they're
not incredible, they're not that exciting,
but they are really useful.
And what though is demonstrate a need, a utility
which people are going to find useful.
So that's the key.
If you are creating application, make sure
that it solves a problem.
Make sure that there's a reason why people
are going to download it.
It can be something practical, like shopping,
or it can be something far more pragmatic,
like, I get bored waiting for the train for
ten minutes every morning, so I want a game
which I can play casually and keep my entertained
for that period.
That's useful.
You need to think about ways in which you
can create something which people are going
to want to use.
The last glorious virtue is an important one.
So important I kind of needed to invent a
word to make it fit into the slides.
It's epicness, "icity."
It's being legendary, it's thinking outside
of the box of creating an app which is a version
of something which you are going to already
see on a Web site.
The reason why I haven't got an image there
is because it's stuff which you haven't considered
yet, something that no one has considered.
It's finding new paradigms and new ways to
use the hardware that haven't been used beforehand.
So there are some really great examples of
this, of companies which have thought beyond
these sort of basic ideas, people like Shazam,
which will listen to the ambient music and
tell you what it is that you're listening
to and give you the opportunity to buy that
music.
It's Google Goggles is another good example,
which lets you use the camera to take photos
of things in your surroundings and tell you
what it is you're looking at.
Or immersive augmented reality, which uses
the compass, GPS, accelerometers, which lets
you stand where you are and overlay contextual
information.
These are really great, really innovative
ways to use this mobile platform.
And it's these sorts of things that you should
be considering and thinking about how you
can create an app which is going to stand
out in a market with tens of thousands of
applications.
So that covers the -- sort of the ten high-level
dos and don'ts.
What I want to do is spend the next few minutes
covering two specific practical examples of
areas within Android which I think as beginners
you'll be able to get a lot of out of.
This is going to be little more technical
and there will be more code.
If you're not comfortable with code, you can
spend the next ten, 15 minutes wondering why
you've come to a developers' conference.
[ Laughter ]
>>Reto Meier: The first thing I want to cover
is services and alarms.
They go together, or at least they should
do, if you are using them the right way.
Services are incredibly powerful.
They're what lets you have these background
data, these applications running in the background.
And because of that, they have the potential
to -- they give you the potential to commit
four of the -- four of the five sins we talked
about, so sloth, gluttony, hostility, and
arrogance are all things you need to be cautious
of and aware of when you're creating your
services.
So what we're going to do now is have a look
at how you can avoid being "that guy."
And that guy is the one who creates the app
that's kind of cool, does something useful,
but you always end up uninstalling it because
it drains all of your battery and you can't
find a way to turn it off properly and it
doesn't give you any of the options that you
need to stop draining all of your resources.
So that's what we want to try and avoid.
These are some of the ways in which you can
go about doing that.
So I think most of us probably know, hopefully,
the way the application life cycle works,
that your background services may be killed
by the run time in order to reclaim resources.
How many of you know what happens next?
Not too many.
Okay.
So what it does is, the run time is then going
to restart your service as soon as it possibly
can.
So it will kill it to gain some resources
for the foreground activity, but it'll try
to restart it as quickly as it can, often
within a second or within a few seconds, if
it possibly can.
So that's what happens by default.
The thing is, as a developer, you know whether
or not that's actually legitimate.
You know whether or not your service needs
to run.
So wherever possible, you should tell the
system, "That's actually not required."
You can do that, as of Android 2, using "on
start" command, which was in services prior
to 2.
The difference between it is that it lets
you return a code which tells the run time
exactly how to react to the service being
killed.
And the return value I want to point you to
today is start not sticky.
So by returning this, you're telling the run
time, if this service gets killed, don't restart
it.
Just let it go.
This is perfect for services which are going
to be happening on a regular basis.
So if you're polling for updates every ten
or 15 minutes, if it misses this particular
update, it's probably not that important.
This is a way for you to be able to work with
the system to keep the system more responsive
and to keep your app and other apps more responsive.
So that's definitely something you want to
consider for any service which performs a
single action which gets repeated on a regular
basis.
Related to that, we talked about background
services, and there's something similar called
a foreground service.
What that is is a service which runs still
invisibly to the user, but which is interacting
with them directly.
So two good examples of that are a music player
and turn-by-turn navigation.
So if you have an application like that, it
needs to run in the foreground.
The thing about foreground services is that
the system treats them the same as it does
foreground activities, which makes it much,
much less likely for them to get killed, which
means that if you have a number of foreground
services, it can have a big impact on the
overall system performance.
The key is to not use them unless you absolutely
have to.
If you do have them running, you should always
give users the opportunity to first see that
it's running and, secondly, to find ways in
which to turn it off.
So if from Android 2 onwards, foreground services
need to have an ongoing notification.
So I would urge you all, if you are developing
for systems prior to 2.0, to use the ongoing
notification anyway.
It's a way for users to be able to say, at
the moment, it's more important for me to
have system resources than to have this application
running.
It's a really important way of being able
to not be hostile and to be able to help the
system to manage its resources effectively.
So we've talked about the way that the run
time can kill background services or help
the -- how you can help the user to kill foreground
services.
The more important thing is for you to kill
your own services.
Services consume resources, they're in the
background.
They should be running for the smallest amount
of time possible.
So to stop them running, you call stopself.
So within your activities -- sorry, within
your services, whenever they complete a task,
and ideally, your services should only be
running in order to fulfill particular tasks
or if they're bound to an activity.
So as soon as the activity goes away, they
should be unbound.
If they're in the background, they should
be completing one task, one action, and then
call stopself.
So a way to be able to implement this is,
again, using the async task, which we talked
about, in combination with start not sticky.
So what we can see here is kicking off an
asynchronous task, that's going to call stop
self.
So we can ensure this is running for the smallest
amount of time possible.
The only thing better than making sure your
services are well managed is not starting
them to begin with.
In fact, you need to ask yourself, do you
actually need a service for what -- for the
action which you are trying to perform?
So the question is, what's the alternative?
And the alternative is alarms and intent receivers.
So intent receivers are a great way to be
able to make your application much more event-driven.
What we're going to do now is have a look
at a way that you can use alarms and intent
receivers to replace a service which would
be running in the background simply to do
regular polling.
And that's definitely not something that you
want to have.
So the way you can do this, the way alarms
work is that they let you set an event to
happen either in the future or on an ongoing
basis in the future.
An intent receiver is a way that you can say
that you want to listen for something, an
intent, a broadcast intent, either from your
own application, a third party's, or, indeed,
the system, and then react accordingly.
So what we're going to look at now is how
to replace this polling with alarms and intent
receivers.
So you start off within your application.
You create a new broadcast receiver implementation.
And with -- "on receive" is where you're going
to perform whatever action you want to have
happen on a regular basis.
In this instance, we're going to start a service.
It's going to be the sort of service which
is going to run up, simply do your update,
and then kill itself.
Once you've created it, you, obviously, need
to include it in your manifest using the XML
text above.
And you include an intent filter now which
is going to specify a broadcast intent to
listen to.
So now whenever the system broadcasts or refreshes
this intent, your application, my receiver,
is going to get spun up and "on receive" is
going to get called and this update is going
to happen.
So how do you get that to happen?
Using alarms.
So what we've done here is we've created a
new alarm using the alarm manager, which creates
a new intent, which is refresh this, which
is going to wake up the device every 15 minutes
and execute this receive handler which we
saw beforehand.
Now, this is really neat, because this all
happens even if your application is totally
not running.
So if it's been killed, once you set these
alarms, they will continue to happen without
your application having to run in the background,
consuming resources.
There is a risk with this particular implementation,
though.
I'm sure you can probably spot what it is.
If you've got ten applications, each of which
set one of these repeating alarms to happen
every 15 minutes and it takes about a minute
for it to complete this update, you're going
to end up with your phone on constantly while
it's performing the updates for all of these
different applications.
So there is a solution for this.
And that's using inexact alarms.
Inexact alarms work almost exactly the same
way, but instead of calling set repeating,
you call set inexact repeating.
What this does is lets the system phase-shift
these alarms which are all going to happen
at close to the same time to happen at the
same time.
So rather than 15 alarms happening over the
course of 15 minutes, you have them all happen
at the same time or very close to each other
in a way that the system is able to optimize.
So this is going to have a dramatic impact
on your resource usage.
If you have something which needs to happen
regularly but doesn't have to happen exactly,
use inexact repeating rather than repeating.
So very quickly, before I run out of time
entirely, I want to have a quick look at location-based
services.
This is something that's really fundamental
to the way mobile apps work.
Location context is really important.
It's also really important to get wrong.
So this is a really simple implementation
of a location listener.
Those of you who have played around with this
beforehand can probably spot the problems
a mile off.
What we are doing wrong is, when we request
our location updates, we're not having any
limits on frequency of those updates.
So this is saying, no matter how much time
has passed since the last one, even if it
was half a second ago, even if the user hasn't
moved, every time the GPS gets a new signal,
I want to fire my code.
What's more, we're specifying the GPS explicitly.
Even worse, we're doing that using a string
literal.
So how do we improve that?
So these are some of the things that we need
to be looking at.
How often do we need to get these updates?
Do we need to use a specific provider?
And what happens if that provider isn't available
in how accurate do we need to be?
What's the impact of all of these things going
to be on our battery life?
And what happens in the case of GPS when it's
going to be jumpy at the beginning?
How do we create that instant positive user
experience where they don't have to wait for
a GPS to settle?
So the first thing we want to do is restrict
those updates.
It's one of the fundamental things we talked
about earlier on, is limiting the number of
updates.
Right here, it's quite simply, we've specified
a minimum frequency, which is -- or maximum
frequency, I should say, which is saying we
don't need updates any more often than every
five minutes.
And we don't really need to know if they've
gone anything less than a kilometer.
So we can put that in really easily.
That's already going to make a dramatic difference
to letting the system manage that GPS resource.
Next, we want to remove that GPS.
So we definitely don't want a string literal.
We don't even want to specify a particular
provider.
We don't know what's going to come out in
the future, we don't know what the user has
enabled and what their preferences are.
By using the "criteria" class, we can specify
the power consumption that we're after, the
accuracy that we require, and a number of
other hardware requirements that we do or
don't need.
So by doing this, we're able to ask the location
manager to get us the best provider based
on what's currently active and available on
the system.
And that's going to have -- that's going to
make sure that we can do a lot of things.
That's going to make sure that we always have
the best provider for the current situation.
It's going to make sure that we only have
active providers so we're not left with not
being able to get location at all just because
the user isn't using GPS and that's what we
would prefer.
So now we've got a much more efficient solution.
And we need to think about what the implications
are for your actual app.
So one of those things is what I mentioned
a little bit earlier on is GPS.
When you start up a GPS, it will bounce around.
You'll have to wait sometimes minutes until
it's a nice, solid, accurate value.
So one solution to this is to implement a
backoff pattern where you're using multiple
location listeners so you can get a result
and as accurate a result as possible before
you're going to back off and let the system
use the much more managed, infrequent update
approach that we talked about.
So how does that look?
So it works much the same way.
So the first thing we're going to do is create
a location listener for our best provider,
the one which uses the criteria we specified
and has the -- the maximum frequency and distance
requirements.
We're also going to implement two location
listeners, one for a course provider and one
for a -- one for a bounce provider, which
is going to take care of the GPS sort of stuff.
And both of those are going to have no restrictions.
And this is what it's going to look like in
code.
We're going to have a look at the on location
change for the course listener at the bottom.
It's going to say, well, I'm going to assume
that the course listener, which is going to
going to be the Wi-Fi cell ID approach, is
going to be able to give us something quickly
albeit not particularly accurately.
I want to grab that and use it so the user
at least has something.
But only once.
Then we're going to use the bounce provider
to say, look, I want every update from the
GPS until it gets better than within sort
of ten meters of accuracy.
At that point, I'm willing to fall back to
our more managed approach.
So this should be able to give us a location
as quickly as possible, and then rapidly sort
of scale down once we increase the accuracy
of our GPS receiver.
So, finally, to summarize, hopefully, by the
end of today or the end of this session, and
certainly there's a lot of other Android sessions
over the next two days that will hopefully
help you to do this, but we want you to be
good developers, not lazy developers.
Think about performance and how it's going
to impact your application.
Think about the user experience, respect your
users, respect the system, and think big.
Think about how you can create something beyond
what's already been done.
So thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
I'm not sure if we have time for questions.
Not at all.
So what I am going to do is, if you have questions,
check out the Wave link.
There is a moderator.
You will be able to post questions there.
I will make sure that all of those get added.
There's also developer.android.com and a number
of other things.
So enjoy your lunch.